[音楽]
こんばんは気づけば全国の心霊スポットを
回ってそうな勢いで心霊スポットに行って
いますはじめ社長ですはい今回はですね
福岡県の九州にある福岡県の心霊スポット
に来ております福岡はそうですね色々調べ
たことあるんですけども福岡も結構心霊
スポットは多めですね見た感じ映画にも
なりましたあの有名な旧犬鳴トンネル結構
盛ですですね福岡心霊スポットが多いん
ですけれどもその中でも僕が今回行く
ところは南畑ダムというダムでございます
うんネットでも結構心霊スポットやばい
心霊スポットとして名が上がっている場所
ですね南畑ダムは洪水の対策そしてこの
近くの水不足解消のために作られたダムだ
と幽霊が出る噂とかがあるっぽくてま過去
に事故や事件が起こったという可能性が
あると言われていますちょっと調べてみ
ましょうああ結構事件が起きてるねまダム
ということで水難事故こう水になんか溺れ
たりとかっていう事件が何件かあったりと
か20年前に女性の遺体が見つかったりだ
とかこれやだなダムの近くに遺体を埋め
たりとか浮かぶ男性の遺体が見つかったり
すごい
なこんなにたくさん起きるんだ事件って
ダム系の心霊スポットでよく言われている
水没集落ダムの下に昔村があったとかこう
人が住んでいたっていうので例が出
るっていうのがあるんですけどもそれも
ちょっと調べてみたところやはり水没して
いる家が何件かあることはもう判明して
いるみたいですね確実な情報ではないん
ですけどやっぱその村の人とダム作るので
ちょっと揉めたりとかそういうこともあっ
たんじゃないかと言われていますでよく
ある現象南畑ダムでよくある霊現象として
は女性の霊が出るというのがめちゃくちゃ
多いらしいですえなんか噂によると
南畑ダムの近くのトイレになんか女性を
これ閉じ込めたのかななんかいじめみたい
なのがあってそれでこう命を立ったとか
あくまで噂なのでわかんないんですけど
あとは子供の霊が出るとも言われてますね
水事故で子供が亡くなったからなのでは
ないかと言われていますでもう1つ言われ
てるのがこの南はダムに行った後に身体や
精神に異常をきたしたそして交通事故に
あったという話もよく聞くとされています
すごいな全部盛だなダムにも霊がいるかも
しれないしこう埋められた人の霊が近くに
いるかもしれないこんな山奥なのにそんな
色んなことが起きてるんだいやちょっと
怖い
なじゃ行けない
よ誰か一緒に来てくれないか
なはじめさんえこの声ははじめ
さん僕です今日もおとし
ますいやあすごいイケメンさん来てくれ
ましたよろしくお願いしますどこんにちは
よろしくお願いします話聞いててどうでし
たいやもうめちゃくちゃすごいというか
全部詰まったとこですねそうだねちょっと
いろんなことが起きすぎてて怖いんです
けどち俺の勝手なジンクスなんだけど
サーベと心霊スポット行ったりすると何か
起きるっていうのがあるのよ確かにアとか
もやばかったじゃんはいまあれはやばかっ
たっすねそんな感じちょっと福岡の心霊
スポット早速南はダム行ってみたいと思い
ますはいでは早速南はだに向かいたいと
思いますよろしくお願いします
いや
怖え
ぺんええええなんか落ちちゃった落ち
ちゃったやばいなんで落ちたやばい突然
なんか取れ
たああやばい怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い
怖い怖いね怖いねなんか突然壊れたんだ
けどえなんかビヨンってなって
さ
えつかなくなっ
たちょっと待ってだるいだるいあオオオ
着きましたきました行こうか
はい暗い
ねご覧くださいホットドッグがダブルで
倒れてますいや3つあるなトリプルホット
だ間にブレンドコヒ添えてやがるよ
とりあえず向かいましょう
か山奥で人もいないからそこはちょっと
なんか気節来れましたねはい近所に人住ん
でるとちょっと声出すと迷惑かかるから
確かにいや怖えで
もあもうすぐそこ
かいや風つよ立ち入り
禁止ここは行っちゃだめですね風すごく
ないいやめっちゃ
強い怖い多分ここ
だこれ
だ見て南はダムここですね
確かにこれすごいよだ見
てもう闇に繋がっ
てるすごいねすごいっすね雰囲気が早速
行ってみましょうかいや風強これ
危く結構子供だったらぶっ飛ばされる
ぐらい強い
ですえ怖くない結構怖いっすマジで
怖いいや怖えあと後ろ見て
みうわやばくない何
も真っ暗
やあこれ皆さんiPhone15だから
綺麗に映ってるだけで真っ黒です
iPhone15すごいぞ見てめっちゃ
綺麗いやいやいやおか真っ暗なんで本当は
すいませんね性能良すぎて綺麗に見えて
ますけど真っ暗ですすごいなこれさ下とか
見えるんかな確か
に終し
ますあ見える見えるiPhone15
すげえなんかすごいね
すごいとりあえず奥まで行きましょう
かこの音は何
だずっとなんかこれカタカタ言ってる
けどあ星綺麗だな待って待って
綺麗な動画になってんだけどiPhone
自星まで映ってるんか何がこんなカタカタ
言ってんだろうね
これ
いやあ風で何かがぶつかってる音がします
ねいや怖え
[音楽]
これこっち側も見てみましょううわこっち
は深いなこっちがダメだねだめだ深すぎて
何も見えない
とりあえず奥まで行ってみましょうか
はいいやこえ
これ何
が何があるんだ奥にマジでわから
ん
ペロペロしてんだおいかなっ気
[音楽]
だ
ここさ何にもないのよ本当にダム以外誰か
来たけどなんかね怖いよね怖い勢なんか人
埋めたりしてるからマジで怖いんだ
けどまで行きましょう
かペロ頼むよ
ペロいいからく
行こう水の音が聞こえ
ますいやあ音が聞こえるだけで何も見え
ない
ですiPhone15で見えないってこと
はマジで見えない多分なんかダムってなん
でこんな怖いイメージあるんだろうね
なんか揉めてるイメージあるよねはいダム
の埋め立てられる場所に昔村があったりし
てそこの人たちのなんかその思いと
か最後までなんか村を潰すになってダムの
を作った人と戦ったりといいうイメージが
あり
ます何これ
触るだけ触ってみていいえなんか銃弾
みたいなあるんだけど銃撃戦あったかここ
でどうしてこんなっできるんだえ本当
だこれ
はまあなんか授業所みたいな感じなのか
な立ち入り禁止になってます
うわ
怖え金強いの本当やばいスマホだけ落ちた
ないにしないとこれはかなり深いダメです
ねお風がやみましたねピタっ
と
ん
こわなんか聞こえ
あちょっと後ろだ気をつけよ本当に誰も来
てないよ
ね来てないですええ
[音楽]
今えなんかここや
ね離れよう
はいこの建物は何なん
だろうあこれで一応ダムの奥までは来まし
た後ろもう1回見れ
[音楽]
ねあ来てない何なんだろう
ね
ああ
そのダムだけじゃなくて注意しべきは人も
埋められてるから
ね周りも怖いよね普通
にうわ風
強やっぱり立ち入り禁止の場所が多いです
ねここも行っちゃダメなんだ
売られ
てる気になるねこういうのあるとめっちゃ
気になり
ますねなんか後ろだよね
はいえ
えなんか聞こえんいや聞こえます
来
てだ俺のズボンがめちゃくちゃ
バタバタしてるちょっと戻るか
はい
[音楽]
さらお全然き
ちゃん
まあこう集落をもし水没させたとしても
それ以上に水不足とかがあったから助かる
目も大きかったから作ったんだと思うん
ですよ
ねま自然壊したり色々あると思うけど悪い
ことばっかりでもないんですよねダム作
りって誰だおめえおめえダムの人かと思っ
たちのじいちゃんダム作ってたガチっすか
うん戻りましょうか
はい
見える白い
のあやばいやばいこの
人待っ
て
[音楽]
やばい
やばクリスマスマジでやられた怖かった
いやめっちゃ怖かったすガチでいるかと
思った
ほらなんかボザんっ
て船あるえ怖い怖い怖いなんかバチバチ
行ってる待って1個行っていいはい風強
すぎて
怖いほらなんかすごくない
さっきほらほらほら本当だ下
か何これ何これ
ちょマイク向けれ
そうほら本当ださっきまでこのなくなかっ
たはいなんかめっちゃいろんな場所で
バシバシ行っ
てるほらほら泳いでえさっき何もなかった
よだって風強くてもいやなかったっす
なかったっすほらほらほら
ほらいやなんかすごい
帰れって言われてる気分いやマジでそう
怖いねいやマジで怖いっ
す風自体の強さは最初と変わってないのに
なんかすごい音が食え
てるあやばい怖い無理ごめんめもう行こう
もう行こう
はい風にくいあさっきの人だ誰はいという
わけで戻ってきました風は強いから
いろんな音はするのはもちろんなんです
けど明らかに行より帰りの方が音が増えて
ましたなんかねすごい水のダムの下から
すごいボコボコ聞こえたしねはいあんな
バチバチ言ってた最初いや絶対言って
なかったっす言ってなかったよね
はいいや
怖え戻る
確かにさっきのやつ
は
うわ
何てクラちゃったえ何持ってやばずる
ごめんいや腰抜けちゃったんす
けど散らないタイプだから片付けしなくて
いいやばいめっちゃ俺パーティーに来た人
みたいにな車あるえ車なくねあれ俺たちの
あれあれそうかえなくなってる車あ本当だ
えさっき止まってなかった普通にいや
止まってまし
たなくなってるえ止まってたよね止まって
まし
たに来たのうわでうくに台車ある
え俺の目はごまかせない
よなんか車い台止まってるおあ本当
だカーセッスうんカーセあるいや怖いっす
ね戻りましょうか寒いし風も強い
し怖いて雰囲気は感じましたね風が
すごかったねいやこれは心霊スポットだわ
多分自然がうわあま最初に話した通りこれ
で終わりというか終わりではなくてこの後
になんかその身体とかはいがなんかやば
いって聞いたのよ事故にあったりとかあ
なるほどこっからそうだからちょっと最後
まで気をつけて帰りたいと思いますはい次
福岡来た時は犬鳴トンネルとか行けたら
いいねあちょっとそうすね記念に行っとき
たいです怒られろ記念はだめ記念はダメな
アニバーサリーじゃないまた心霊スポの
動画でお会いしましょうで
[音楽]
は